pocos instantes después del ataque la
ola de reacciones de mandatarios
europeos invadió las redes sociales el
primero de todos fue el cercano vecino
de la ciudad de niza el italiano
giuseppe conté el infame ataque a la
catedral de niza no debilitará nuestro
frente común en defensa de los valores
de la paz y la libertad nuestras
convicciones son más fuertes que el
fanatismo el odio y el terror estamos
cerca de las familias de las víctimas y
de nuestros hermanos franceses si la
mayoría de los mensajes mostraron la
conmoción internacional una intervención
desató el rechazo el ex primer ministro
malasio mohammad mattis echó leña al
fuego en twitter una declaración que
minutos después fue borrada los
musulmanes tienen derecho a estar
enojados y a matar a millones de
franceses por las masacres del pasado
afortunadamente el llamamiento de las
autoridades religiosas musulmanas de
francia fue diferente el consejo francés
de culto musulmán pide a los líderes
musulmanes que cierren sus mezquitas
hasta nuevo aviso a partir de esta noche
después de la oración nocturna y que
usan este último momento de oración como
una oportunidad para él
y el recuerdo en memoria de las víctimas
un mensaje global de rechazo hacia el
atentado
la iglesia católica llamó a la paz ya la
hermandad entre religiones